hey guys my name is jeff mcdonald it's
the 24th of june today and you're tuned
into kings what news first up I just
like to say apples go out to nintendo
president Satoru water in regard to his
recent health issues and we wish him a
speedy recovery alrighty let's do news
well stop have you ever wondered what
gta5 would look like in a first-person
perspective well whether you have will
you haven't somebody made a mod to that
effect and here it is you're a gamer dug
up two videos by youtube user xbl
toothpick who used a modded xbox 360 to
force first-person perspective there are
obviously a few rough parts like
graphical glitches and seeing the inside
of your character's head bolt turning
but it's kind of cool to get a sense of
what the game might be like and how GTA
6 might play when we're all using
virtual reality that's purely
speculation please don't quote me on
that this is our video journalist lose
their jobs we already knew that long
time Metal Gear Solid voice actor David
Hayter was being shafted 424 actor
Kiefer Sutherland from the role of snake
in Metal Gear Solid 5 but now after a
long time speculation it seems that
haters confirmed yet again that he will
have no role whatsoever in the upcoming
title it seems the gamers may have been
badgering he'd retired since he recently
posted on Twitter guys for the millions
and last time I am NOT in Metal Gear 5
in any way at all no joke just not true
story a barroom is apparent fondness for
punctuation and short sentences I think
what we can gather from this is that the
dude is probably not going to be infant
and pain series creator Hideo Kojima
explained the change in voice actor by
saying it's a new type of metal gear
game and we wanted to have this
reflected in the voice actor as well
last up today the often leaky amazon
france has listed a ps4 hardware bundle
including the Last of Us remastered but
since its unannounced there's a chance
that the listing won't last I really
need to stop talking about the last of
us lost in these scripts amazon france
whose rap sheet for accidentally leaking
bundles and games is about as long as my
arm posted that the ps4 and Last of Us
remastered bundle will include the game
a 500 gigabyte black system and a
controller the list
indicates it'll go for 429 euros which
is about five hundred and eighty five
bucks so Nene hasn't officially
confirmed the bundle at this stage but
given that one of the last things amazon
friends accidentally leaked with GTA 5
on pc we can suspect this one is
probably gonna come to fruition two
areas the amazon france get your [ __ ]
together let me know if you'd pick up a
ps4 The Last of Us remastered or if
there's another game that already has or
probably will in the future encourage
you to take the new generation consoles
one that is it for me today thanks for
joining me yet again and be sure to pop
I again tomorrow or it's just me in this
page and it gets kind of weird I'll see
you soon